So just a little bit more
detail of how TOR works.
So it's called onion routing,
is what I think the example we had was
sort of doing something like that.
It uses onion routing.
So to start,
the client we are talking about
uses a director service to
get a set of TOR nodes.
These nodes would then help us route
the message from Alice to Bob's website.
You pick a random set and
order it, so the message is
going to go from one to the next
in the order that we come up with.
Alice is going to prepare her message
and creates these onion layers,
so in the end it's going to
go to Bob's website, but
then we know it's going to be sent
to Bob's website by the last node.
And its predecessor is going to send
it to that and things like that,
so the onion layers that we're talking
about essentially, when you peel one,
you know where it goes next,
okay, but that's all.
You don't see any further down
through the layers beyond that.
So we peel one layer.
We know who to send it to next in
this order that we're talking about.
And that node is going to peel another
layer, and send it to Its successor, and
we're going to continue like that.
And this peeling of the layers actually
is done through encryption using keys,
you encrypted with someone's public key.
So, only they can decrypt it because
they have the corresponding private key,
and that's how this thing works.
So that's anonymous communication.
Well, you can, Alice doesn't
have to say that it's Alice
if Bob's website demands some
sort of identity for her.
You can create sort of fictional or
pseudo identities,
you can have multiple one of those.
So somebody when you switch your
identity they can't say that Alice is
doing A, B, and C, if you switched
after A, then whoever is tracking
would think B is being done by somebody
other than whoever had done A.
So, psuedo-anonymity is not a way
by which we tried to sort of defeat
the tracking and making the kind of
inferences that we're talking about.
And of course,
we talked about aggregation and
privacy enhancing transformations
like anonymization of data, and
diversity in data, so someone is
not able to inference back to you.
This must be some information
about you and things like that, so
the variety of this technologies and
techniques that one can use to
improve privacy to if not defeat,
at least reduce that effectiveness
of tracking, and that happens in
collection of information that can
be tied to a particular identity.
This technology sort of
helps us disrupt that.